[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في سعه اخباريه مفصله
من العربيه نبداها بالعناوين
وزير الدفاع الروسيه فقدوا قوته في
دونيسكو والدفاع الاوكرانيه تطالب اوروبا
بارسال ربع مليان قذيفه شهريا
حرب الاوكرانيه استطلاع لراي يظهر ان 80%
من الروس يفيقون في الرئيس بوتين
المبعوث الامريكي الى ايران يدعو لمحاسبه
المسؤولين عن تسميم فتيات ايران
ارتفاع مخيف لحاله الاصابه بحمى في 13
ولايه سودانيه وصحه تحصي حتى الان 600 بل
6500 حاله
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا نبدا النشره المتطورات
الحرب الاوكرانيه حيث تتواصل المعارك
العنيف شرق البلاد وخصوصا في منطقه بخموت
حيث يشتد الخناق على القوات الاوكرانيه
التي لجات الى تفجير الجسور مراسل عربي
مشاهدينا افاد في هذا السياق بان القوات
الاوكرانيه فجرت يسرا للسكك الحديديه على
نهر باخبوت القريب من الطريق السريع الذي
يصل بخمت بمدينه شاسوفيار هذا وافاد
الصحيفه
الى زملائه في دول الاتحاد الاوروبي الى
ارسال 250 الف قذيفه مدفعيه شهريا الى
كييف لسد النقص الحاد الذي يمكن ان يحد من
التقدم في ساحه المعركه ووفقا للمسؤول
العسكري الاوكراني فان قوات بلاده تستخدم
20% فقط من كميه القذائف التي يمكنها
استخدامها بسبب نقص الامدادات وقدر وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني ان يكون الحد الادنى من
متطلبات الاداء الناجحين المهام القتاليه
60 % على الاقل من الذخيره الكامله
من جهته اكد رئيس وزراء اوكرانيا ان جيش
بلاده يتبع معايير الناتو في القتال
ويستخدم اسلحته واكد ان وجود كيا في
الناتو امر حقيقي بحكم الامر الواقع
الابواب المفتوحه ليست كافيه بالنسبه لنا
اوكرانيا تسمع هذه الجمل منذ سنوات نريد
ونتوقع قرارات حاسمه من حلفائنا جيشنا
يقاتل باستخدام معدات الناتو وقواتنا
المسلحه تعمل بمعايير الناتو وجودنا في
الناتو امر واقع
على الارض افاد مراسل العربيه بان وزير
الدفاع الروسي تفقد وحداتي وكتائب الشرق
العسكريه في منطقه دونياسك واشرف على مسار
العمليه العسكريه في محور المنطقه حيث
استمع شويغو الى تقارير القاده الروس على
ارض المعركه التي تدخل عامها الثاني واشرف
على مسائل النشر الامن للجنود وعامل
الوحدات الطبيه كما قلد شويغو اوسيمه
الشجاعه لبعض الجنود في دونيسك
تشهدها مدينه بخموت منذ اسابيع لم تحسم
بعد
لكن احتدام الوضع فيها لم يغفي العيون
موسكو يوما عن واجهه اوكرانيا نحو البحر
الاسود
اليوم تزداد مخاوف اوكرانيا من شن روسيا
هجوما مباغتا من جهه الغرب اي من اقليم
ترانسنيستريا المولدوفي الذي تتمركز فيه
قوات روسيه خصوصا بعد ان اعلن مستشار
الرئيس الاداره العسكريه في اوديسا تسريع
وتيره عمليات تحصين المدينه لمنع تعرضها
لهجوم حده التوتر تصاعدت على حدود هذا
الاقليم بعد ان اعلن الجيش الاوكراني ان
روسيا تنشر سفنا اضافيه بما في ذلك خمس
حاملات صواريخ وغواصتان في البحر الاسود
خطوه روسيا العسكريه بحريا ارفقتها
باتهامات لقياف بتحضيرها استفزازا عسكريا
ضد اقليم ترانسينيستريا هذه الاتهامات
كانت كفيله بتعزيز فرضيه التوجه الروسي
لاطلاق مرحله جديده من الصراع بمشاركه
الانفصاليين
الموالين لموسكو
اهميه فتح هذه الجبهه تكمن بالسعي الى
تعقيد الموقف اكثر امام كييف من خلال
توسيع رقعه المواجهات من ناحيه والعمل
بشكل مباشر على محاوله السيطره على ميناء
اوديسا في اقصى غربي البلاد من ناحيه اخرى
في الاجتماع الذي استمر اكثر من ساعه بجعل
روسيا تدفع ثمن حربها في اوكرانيا كما شدد
على اهميه استمرار التضامن العالمي مع
الشعب الاوكراني والجهود المستمره لتوفير
الامن والمساعد الانسانيه والاقتصاديه
والسياسيه لكيف
فرضت الولايات المتحده عقوبات على سته
مواطنين روس بينهم نائب وزير العدل وقضاه
وحسب بيان الخزانه الامريكيه فان العقوبات
جاءت لمسؤوليه هؤلاء عن سجن المعارض
الروسي فلاديمير كارا مرزا وتمنع العقوبات
الجديده هؤلاء المسؤولين الروس من الوصول
الى حسابات بنكيه امريكيه ومؤسسات ماليه
اخرى وايضا تشمل حظرا على التاشيره
بدوره اجرى وزير العدل الامريكي زياره
مفاجئه لمدينه يلافيف غرب اوكرانيا زياره
يجدد خلالها المسؤول الامريكي تصميم
واشنطن على محاسبه روسيا على الجرائم التي
ارتكبتها في اوكرانيا حسبت تعبيره وقال
جارلان وزاره العدل الامريكيه تعمل مع
نظيرتها الاوكرانيه للتحقيق في تلك
الجرائم
في الاثناء اعلن المدعي العام الاوكراني
اندريه
وقال الوداع العام الاوكراني ان هذا سيسمح
للمدعي العام للمحكم الجنائي الدوليه
بالتحقيق بشكل كامل في الجرائم الدوريه
التي ارتكبتها في اوكرانيا
وصلت رئيسه البرلمان الاوروبيه الى
العاصمه الاوكرانيه في زياره مفاجئه مثال
عبرت في تغيير على تويتر عن فرحتها
بالعوده الى اوكرانيا وقالت يسرني ان اكون
مع من ضحوا بكل شيء من اجل قيمنا وذلك
بحسب تعبيرها
مشاهدينا اظهر استطلاع جديد اجراه معهد
فيستوم المقارنه من الدوائر الحكوميه
الروسيه ارتفاع مستوى ثقه الشعب الروسي في
الرئيس بوتين خلال الفتره الممتده من 20
الى 26 من فبراير بنسبه واحد من عشره نقطه
مئويه لتبلغ بذلك 80% مشيرا الى ان 80% من
المشاركين في الاستطلاع بشان الثقه
بالرئيس الروسي اجابوا بشكل ايجابي
الاستطلاع اظهر انه يخص تقييم عمل الرئيس
خلال نفس الفتره فقد ارتفع بنسبه ثلاث من
عشره نقطه مئويه لابلغ بذلك نحو 77% كما
اوضح الاستطلاع ان نسبه التقييم الايجابي
لعمل الحكومه الروسيه بلغت
52%. من المشاركين
دعا المبعوث الامريكي الخاص بايران روبرت
مالي الى محاسبه المسؤولين عن تسمم فتيات
في مدارس ايرانيه وقال مالي على تويتر انه
يجب ان تتوقف حالات تسمم هذه ومحاسبه
الجناه مضيفا انه لا ينبغي لاحد ان يمنع
فتيات ايران مواصله التعليم الذي يعد حقا
من حقوق الانسان وضروريا لتعزيز الامن
الاقتصادي للمراه
خصبه للابتلاع اعذار النظام الايراني
وامتصاص اخطائه تحولت لها دول الغرب فهناك
يرمي انتهاكاته بمجالاتها المتعدده ليزعم
وقوف من يصفهم بالاعداء خلف كل ما يجري في
بلاده
فصول قمع الاحتجاجات لم تنتهي بعد ليتسرب
عبرها غاز تسبب بتسمم طالبات في المدارس
هذه ايضا تهمه الصقها بطريقه ما الرئيس
الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي بالغرب الذي يسعى
وفق تعبيره لاشاعه التوتر والذعر بين
الطلاب واولياء امورهم واثاره الاضطرابات
في ايران
معاناه الفتيات الايرانيات وسلبهن حق
التعليم بات موضع قلق دول غربيه عده بينها
الولايات المتحده والمانيا فهجمات السم
الخفيف فسرها السياسيون على انها استهداف
من قبل الجماعات المتشدده المعارضه لتعليم
الفتيات
يجب ان تتمكن الفتيات من الذهاب الى
المدرسه بلا خوف هذا حقهن الانساني ببساطه
يجب التحقيق بشكل كامل في كل الحالات
حالات تسمم متوسطه لمئات الفتيات اعلنت
عنها وزاره الصحه الايرانيه خلال الاشهر
القليله الماضيه وبين السوق الاتهامات
والقاء اللوم وجه رئيس وزير الداخليه
والامن بمتابعه قضايا التسمم في المدارس
فيما كلف رئيس مجلس الشورى محمد باقر
قليباث اربعه لجان برلمانيه بالتحقيق
واكتشاف اسباب الحوادث وقد تم القاء القبض
على ثلاثه اشخاص اشتبه بتورطهم في القضيه
لكن الاجهزه الامنيه نفت اكتشافها لماده
سامه قد تكون السبب في تسمم الطلبه ونبقى
في ايران حيث نظم محتجون في شوارع مدينه
الزهدان عاصمه بروجيستان جنوب شرق ايران
مظاهره ضد نظام الملالي ورفع المحتاجون
البلوشي الذين خرجوا عقب صلاه الجمعه في
مظاهره رفعوا لافتات تحمل شعار الموت
للظالم شاهن كان او مرشدا
الله اكبر
[تصفيق]
افادت وكاله الانباء العراقيه بان هيئه
النزاهه بان هيئه النزاهه اصدرت اوامر
بالقبض على اربعه من كبار المسؤولين في
حكومه رئيس الوزراء السابق مصطفى الكاظمي
والحجز على اموالهم بينهم وزير الماليه
السابقه لعلاوي وقالت الوكاله ان الاوامر
شملت مديره مكتب رئيس الوزراء السابق رائد
جوحي وسكرتير الشخصي لرئيس مجلس الوزراء
السابق احمد نجاتي والمستشار الاعلامي
لرئيس مجلس الوزراء في الحكومه السابقه
مشرف عباس
واشارت عفوا واشارت الهيئه الى انها امرت
بالقبض على هؤلاء المسؤولين والحجز على
اموالهم المنقوله وغير المنقوله لتسهيرهم
والاستيلاء على مبالغ بل مبالغ الامانات
الضريبيه
نشاتنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
هزه ارضيه بقوه اربع درجات فاصله واحده
على مقاس ريختر فاضرب المناطق الحدوديه
التركيه السوريه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد نواصل نشاط من
السودان حيث وقعت كيانات منتميه لاقليم
شرق السودان منها المجلس الاعلى
والعموديات والجبهه الشعبيه المتحده
للتحديد والعداله وقعت على اعلان للمبادئ
الاجتماعيه والسياسيه وشمل اعلان المبادئ
عاده من القضايا من ابرزها اقامه منبر
تفوضي لا يستثني اي مكون من مكونات
الاقليم وتكوين لجنه دائمه للمصالحه بين
مكوناتها هذا وكان اقليم شرق السودان شاهد
اقتتالا قبريا في مناطق مختلفه على مر
السنوات الثلاث الماضيه
في السودان ايضا يخشى خبراء صحه من انتشار
كبير لحمى بعد ان كشفت وزاره الصحه
السودانيه عن ارتفاع مخيف لحاله الاصابه
بهذا المرض حيث بلغت
6500 حاله في 13 ولايه سودانيه
في السودان شوارع واسواق تبدو حركتها
عاديه لكن داخل ازقتها مرض يجول ساكنها
ففي هذا المكان تحديدا الصوره مختلفه
سيارات اسعاف تقف على اهبه الاستعداد
وممرات المستشفيات بات التعج بالمرضى
فشبحوا حمى لم يعد يميز بين كبير وصغير
ولا بين ولايه واخرى
ارقام فلكيه كشفت عنها وزاره الصحه
السودانيه فحالات الاصابه بهذا المرض بلغت
سته الاف وخمسمائه في ثلاثه عشره ولايه
احنا بنحتاج لانه يكون العمل شامل لكل
الولايه لانه في بؤر ممكن تكتشف فهي لحظه
انتشار المرض يبدو انه اصبح امرا واقعا
فالاصابات وصلت العاصمه الخرطوم وللدقه
اكثر مناطق ام درمان وام بده وكارري غربي
العاصمه في وقت يعاني النظام الصحي فيه
ازمات انهكت كاهله كما نعلم ان النظام
الصحي في السودان يعاني كثير من التحديات
مما يستدعي التعاون مع الجهات العالميه
وزاره الصحه السودانيه اتخذت التدابير
اللازمه لمجابهه المرض والتقليل من حده
انتشاره لكنها حذرت من تفاقم الاوضاع
بحلول موسم الخريف بعد اقل من شهرين
تعيش مئات الاسر اليمنيه في منطقتي
الكويحه والطوير الواقعتين بالقرب من خطوط
تماس الحرب مديريه مكبنه غربيه تعز تعيش
حياه ماساويه قاسيه جراء الاتهاكات
الحوثيه التي تمارس بحقهم وتتعرض تلك
الاسر يوميا للقمص والقصف الحوثي ما
يجعلهم يعيشون في حصار دائم وهم داخل
منازلهم
ثمانيه اعوام من الحرب عاشوا فيها الامرين
حصار اطبقتهم ميليشيات الحوث عليهم من
الغرب وتدهور معيشي وضعهم في دائره الفقر
فلا الحياه تيسرت في منطقه الكويحه غربي
تعز ولا المشاهد الداميه المخطوطه ببنادق
الميليشيات غابت عن اذهان المدنيين فانا
الحوثيين بهذا المكان يمنعوهم من ضرب
العلم ويمنعهم من الزراعه في بعض الاماكن
يقول لك هذا نحن نختفي فيها الاطقام او
هذا نستخدمه يعني كان معانا شديده جدا
معانا المواطن يعني بشكل عام لذلك اضطر
كثير من الناس القادرين للهجره من المكان
والنزوح من المكان نزحوا الى عده اماكن
الى تعز الى منطقه جبل حبشي الى منطقه
البيرين وطبعا الى حد الان نازحين بذات
المشاهد الداميه اذا فقد اكثر من عشرين
مواطنا حياتهم بالقناصات الحوثيه والالغام
فالطريق هذا الذي يربط المنطقه بمدينه
البارح بات اليوم خطرا عليهم بعد ان رس
الحوتيه الموت على امتداده مانعه اي شيء
يحاول السير عليه حتى وان كان قدم بعير
انا ايش عيش ذنكا تمام ولا لا ولم يوجد
عندنا مواد غذائيه
ولم يوجد لدينا بعض من القرى ما فيش
مواصلات لديهم للبيت
مقطوعه تماما لا نقدر لا نطلع ولا ننزل من
البيوت المحلات هذه مغلقه بسبب الحرب
الحوثي على المنطقه كما تشوفونها مغلقه
وكانت مصدر استرزاق لبعض الاسر
فاليوم اصبحت خاويه ونزح هل هذا اهل المحل
هذا وخرجوا من المنطقه بسبب الحرب حاله
رعب يوميه يعيشها اكثر من 600 اسره يمنيه
في مناطق التماس الحرب حياه ماساويه عند
الريف الغربي لتعز عشرات المنازل والمنشات
الحيويه استهدفت بالقذاء في الحوثيه
ومحلات تجاريه هنا اغلقت ابوابها امام
المدنيين منذ اجتياح الحوثيين للمنطقه في
الريف الغربي لتعز وفي منطقه الكويحه هذه
الواقعه في خطوطه التماس الحرب تعيش
العشرات من الاسر حياه ماساويه جراء حالات
القنص والقصف التي تمارسها الميليشيات
الحوثيه بحقهم ليل نهار ال سعيد العربيه
تعز
اعلان رئيس التونسي سعيد انه انا الاوان
لمحاسبه المتربصين بالشعب بحسب وصفه سعيد
قال ان الاتحاد للتونسي للشغل له الحريه
لتنظيم المظاهرات لكن ليس في دعوه الاجانب
المشاركه فيها وان ذلك امر غير مقبول
مضيفا ان هناك من يريد الافلات من
المحاسبه
ولكن من يريد ان يبدو بعض الاشخاص الاجانب
للتظاهر في تونس
وهذا امر غير مقبولا على اي مقياس من
المقاييس
لتكن معاملاتهم معهم كمؤسسات
ولكن تونس ليست ضيعه او بستانا
وذكر رئيس التونسي بمن تورط في الفساد
ومحاوله اغتيال رئيس الدوله وانه انا
الاوان لمحاسبتهم على اي شيء يحتاجون
اليوم
على
على المحاسبه
على من تورته في الفساد
هل هناك تضييق في الحريات
هل هناك دوله في العالم
تقبل
بان يعمل بعض الاطراف على اغتيال رئيس
الدوله
ولا تتم محاسبتهم بل هم تحت
حمايه الامن
اعلن مركز رصد الزلازل الاوروبي المتوسط
ان زلزالا بقوه اربع درجات فاصله واحد على
مقياس ريختر ضرب المناطق الحدوديه التركيه
السوريه وقال المركز الاوروبي ان الزلزال
وقع فجر اليوم السبت عند حوالي الساعه
الثالثه بتوقيت مضيفا ان مركزه كان على
بعد 14 كيلومترا شمال شرق مدينه انطاكيا
التركيه وعلى عمق 10 كيلومترات
قال رئيس تركيا رجب طيب اردوغان ان بلاده
حددت
214,608 مباني في مناطق الزلزال بحاجه
للهدم الفوري اذا تضررها من الزلزال واضاف
اردوغان ان الاعداد النهائيه للوحدات
السكنيه والمنازل الريفيه المزمعه انشائها
ستتضح قريبا مع انتهاء عمليات ازاله
الانقاض
وفي شان السياسي تركي اعلنت زعيمه حزب
الخير المعارض التركي ميرال اكشينار عن
رفض حزبها ترشيح زعيم المعارضه ورئيس حزب
الشعب الجمهوري كملك في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه القادمه واوضحت اكشينار ان خمسه
زعماء من قاده احزاب الطاوله السداسيه
قرروا ترشيحكار اجلو رغم كل المؤشرات التي
تؤكد تقدم رئيس بلديه اسطنبول اكرم امام
بابلو ورئيس بلديه انقره ماسوريا افاش في
استطلاعات الراي مؤكده ان حزبها لن يرضخ
رضوه الطاوله السداسيه بترشيحك
هذا ويلف الغموض وضع احزاب المعارضه بعد
تفاهم لم يدم لساعات بينها على مرشح مشترك
الامر الذي قد يضعه موقفها بشكل كبير في
الانتخابات المقبله خمسه وسبعون يوما فقط
تفصل الشارع التركيه على الانتخابات
الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه التي ستجرى مع تاكيد
اردوغان على ان الموعد لم يتغير وسيكون
بتاريخ 14 من مايو المقبل وفق تقرير صادر
عن وكاله تيبلومبرغ تمر المعارضه التركيه
بازمه خانقه بسبب الفشل في الاتفاق على
مرشح مشترك لمنافسه الرئيس التركي الذي
اتهم الاحزاب المعارضه بالفوضى والانقسام
بشان قضايا تتعلق باداره البلاد على حسب
تعبيره
ليكن هذا واضحا للجميع هذه الامه ستفعل ما
هو ضروري في الرابع عشر من مايو الشعب
التركي سيرد على هؤلاء المغرضين ولم يابه
لمن يردد الشعارات والمقولات الفارغه
توحيد جبهه المعارضه في هذه الانتخابات
بات ضروريه لكسب المعركه السياسيه وفق
مراقبين وفشلوا الحكومه في التعاطي مع
عمليه الانقاذ والاغاثه سيشكل ورقه رابحه
بالنسبه لها حيث ان قاده الطاوله السداسيه
للمعارضه التركيه تقول انها ستعلن خلال
ايام مرشحها المشتركه لخوض الانتخابات
الرئاسيه ووسط التكهنات المتداوله اكد
زعيم الحزب الصالح القومي التركيه المعارض
ان الحزب لن يستسلم لمحاولات محاصرته حيث
طرح ترشيح رئيس بلديه انقره من سوريا واش
ورئيس بلديه اسطنبول اكرم امام اوغلو لخوض
الانتخابات الرئاسيه لكن الاحزاب الخمسه
الاخرى لم تقبل بذلك وقامت بترشيح كمالكا
لجدار اوغلو لخوض الانتخابات الرئاسيه
تضارب التصريحات طرح سيناريوهات المتعدده
ابرزها خروج المعارضه باكثر من مرشح بهدف
ارباك ساحه المؤيدين للرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان وسط تحليلات تشير الى ارتفاع حدود
المعارضه في تحقيق فوز على اردوغان بعد
كارثه الزلزال من جهه او تصويت اقل من نصف
الناخبين لصالح حزب العداله والتنميه ما
سيسمح للرئيس التركي بالتغلب في صناديق
الاقتراع اشار الى انهم توصلوا الى
احتفلت العربيه بعيدها العشرين وسط حضور
كبير لموظفيها الحاليين والمؤسسين ومشاركه
من ضيوف وصحافيين من مختلف العالم العربيه
تجدد عهدها في عيدها العشرين بمواصله
رساله
اجواء احتفاليه سادت غرفه اخبار قناه
العربيه روح معنويه عاليه بعيديها العشرين
عقدان من المهنيه والمثابره وسنوات من
الفخر بالمشاهد والمتابعه الثاقبه حول
العالم
اليوم يوم تاريخي مميز العربيه يوم نتذكر
في كل انجازات العربيه خلال الفتره
الطويله هذه وهي انجازات من اول يوم
انطلاق في العربيه انطلقت في قناه قدمت
المهنيه قدمت الموضوعيه قدمت الخطاب
الاعلامي المعتدل
مرحبا بكم في غرفه اخبارنا
الاحتفالات بدات مبكرا مع الساعات الاولى
من اليوم ببرنامج صباح العربيه جمع
ايقونات الماضي والحاضر جنبا الى جنب
لاستحضار لحظاتهم التي لا تنسى محمد
استعدنا شريط ذكرياتنا مع اطلاق النشره
الاولى لقناه العربيه في الثالث من مارس
عام 2003 كنا على الهواء مباشره مع طالب
كنعان واليوم عشنا معه هذه اللحظه مجددا
ما زلنا في حاله نوستالجيا التي رسمت على
وجوه زملائنا داخل قناه العربيه بنبره
صوتهم القوي ومع كل ضربه على اوتار
الجيتار
مهد الطريق لانطلاقه يوم مثير
[موسيقى]
لعشرين سنه نجوم المجتمع من مختلف انحاء
العالم شاركوا العربيه بعيدها العشرين انا
اتابع قناه العربيه منذ عشرين سنه كل سنه
وقناه العربيه القناه الرائده اللي
بتنقللنا اهم الاخبار القناه اللي فيها
جزء من يومياتنا ويا رب عقبال 100 سنه من
النجاح والتنوير اهني قناتنا الرائعه
والاكثر من رائعه العربيه مناسبه مرور 20
عام على تاسيس التي تمر من هنا
لهما موضع مميز على مدار اليوم زملائنا
الذين وضعوا حياتهم على المحك في سبيل
صناعه القصه الصحفيه لم ننسى تضحياتهم
خسرت قناه العربيه مرسلتها في العراق زميل
اطوار بهجت اضافه الى
زميليعاود مطارده شغفه الاخباري زميون
الصحفي جواد كاظم بعد ان نجى سابقا من
هجوم ارهابي عاد الى شاشتنا وظهر بشكل خاص
مع نجله كريم
وهذه
فعرف انه عندي نشره على الهواء وهذه قلت
له تعال حتى تصدق انه احنا خلف الكاميرا
كان موجود يعني
التقارير واللقاءات والاخبار العاجله لا
تتوقف لكن في الاثناء ننتظر دوما عوده
زملائنا بسلام من تغطياتهم في المناطق
الساخنه بدايه الحرب كان في عنا طاقم من
كريستيان بيشري مذيعه والمصور طلال المصري
كانوا في اوكرانيا قبل بدايه الحرب لاعداد
بعض التق
قيمه للعشرين سنه اللي مرت من من القناه
عربيه
انتهاء اليوم اجتمعت عائله عربيه لتعزيز
هذه الخطوه البعيده التي قطعناها في سماء
الاعلام لنستعد لانطلاقه جديده نحو مستقبل
واعد وفي الذاكره ماض نعتز به كل العمل
هذا بجهودكم انتم باخلاصكم بعملكم انا جدا
جدا فخور اني اكون زميل معكم اليوم وجدا
فخور في العمل معكم اشوف كل العمل
والتضحيات والعمل المستمر وان شاء الله
عشرين سنه قادمه شكرا
[تصفيق]
مشاهدينا نلتقي الان الى الخرطوم لمتابعه
كلمه نائب رئيس مجلس السياده السودانيه
الفريق محمد حمدان دقله في الحلقه
النقاشيه التي نظمتها مفوضيه السلام مشان
اتفاقيه
لتوقيع اتفاق السلام في اكتوبر من العام
بالتزامنا بتنفيذ اتفاقيه بالاتفاقيه نجدد
امامكم اليوم حرصنا على المضي قدما في
تنفيذ بنود الاتفاقيه وفقا للمصفوفه
المتحدثه
[تصفيق]
حتى ينعم شعبنا بالامن والاستقرار وعوده
النازحين واللاجئين الى مناطقهم الاصليه
وتوفير وتوفير الخدمات الضروريه لهم وندعو
الاخوه في اطراف العمليه السلميه
الى مضاعفه العمل
وتنسيق والتنسيق الجهود بذات الروح الطيبه
من اجل تنفيذ هذه المصفوفه وبهذه المناسبه
نتقدم بجزيل الشكر والامتنان لحكومه وشعب
جمهوريه جنوب السودان الشقيقه بقياده
فقامت الرئيس الفاكر ميار الدين وفريق
الوساطه برصد المستشار تدق الواد
والسكرتاريه وللدامنين الاتفاق والاطراف
العمليه السلميه ولكل من بذل جهدا في سبيل
انجاح الورشه حتى خرجت بهذه المصروبه
الحضور الكريم ندعو المجتمع الاقليمي
والدولي والمنظمات الاقليميه والدوليه
والمانحين الى حشد الدعم المال والفني
للمساعده في اكمال تنفيذ بنود اتفاقيه
السلام
خاصه في الجانب التنموي ومشروعات عاده
النازحين واللاجئين والترتيبات الامنيه
وقد تلاقينا بشريات خلال زيارتنا الاخيره
الى دوله الامارات العربيه الشقيقه بتنفيذ
مشروعات لدعم مسيره التنميه والاستقرار في
مجالات المياه والطرق وغيرها من البشريات
التي تسهم في استكمال عمليه السلام وفي
الختام نؤكد حرصنا واهتمامنا بتنفيذ اتفاق
جبل السلام السودان ونجدد الدعوه لحركات
غير الموقعه الى الانضمام لمسيره السلام
ونعمل ان تتواصل جهودكم من خلال هذه
الورشه والبدء في تنفيذ المصوفه وفقا
للجدول نكتفي بهذا القدر وكنا معكم في
متابعه لكلمه نائب رئيس مجلس السياده
السوداني الفريق محمد حمدان في الحلقه
النقاشيه التي نظمتها مفوضيه السلام بشان
اتفاق الجباء وقد قارنا نؤكد على التزامنا
بتطبيق اتفاق شبال السلام ولابد من دعم
دوري لتطبيق اتفاق السلام في السودان
مشاهدينا بالعوده الى سياق نشرتنا اعلنت
القياده المركزيه الامريكيه عن تنفيذها مع
شركاء اخرين 48 عمليه ضد عناصر تنظيم داعش
في العراق وسوريا الشهر الماضي واوضحت
القياده ان هذه العمليات اسفرت عن مقتل 22
عنصرا من التنظيم واعتقال خمسه وعشرين